en este pueblo de la región de jarquín
justo en la frontera con rusia catherine
a chats oa inspectora de la oficina
local está investigando junto con la
policía los presuntos crímenes de guerra
de los soldados rusos en contra de la
población ucraniana parte de este sótano
sirvió como cárcel está húmedo frío y
apesta orina
tampoco
la gente fue retenida aquí para ser
torturada por eso ahora estamos
inspeccionando el sitio junto con
investigadores expertos de un grupo
experto revisa todo mira por todas
partes este no es el único sitio de
tortura que han encontrado en cosas ya
lo pan
los investigadores se percataron de otro
similar con los bomberos de la zona
varios testigos dijeron a la policía que
el sótano de esta estación de tren se
utilizaba como cámara de tortura el
equipo toma muestras de adn de varios
objetos en el sótano para enviarlas a
analizar
durante nuestra inspección encontramos
cinta adhesiva y la estamos examinando
por que probablemente la usaron para
amarrar las manos de las víctimas soft
este hombre de la localidad un antiguo
soldado ucraniano que pidió permanecer
bajo el anonimato pasó cinco días en el
sótano de la estación antes de ser
trasladado a otra prisión y sufrió
tratos inhumanos a manos de las tropas
rusas
uno de ellos me interrogó sobre mi
servicio y mi puesto en el ejército me
bajó los pantalones y me dijo que me
acostara horizontalmente tomo una pieza
de hierro y la sujetó a mi pene dijo
responderás después de cinco descargas
eléctricas estaba tratando de golpear mi
cabeza contra la pared
yo sólo gritaba fue horrible
dice que se siente aliviado por la
presencia de los investigadores
aliviados pero aún roto